all right we're talking with Suzy in Los
Angeles this is the Dave Ramsey show
Suzie left Idaho left their home behind
it got tore up by renters they've ended
up cleaning it up putting it on the
market for a short sale and that's about
how far we got in the story so so you're
supposed to put the house on the market
for a short sale and what happened Suzie
um so we it didn't actually we wouldn't
actually put it on the market until
August and um in October we and they put
it on that much of for 67,000 and at the
time we we hit up 75 um in October we
got a offer for 60,000 cash and they did
not accept it or decline it they just
kind of ignored it and on the last day
of October we were notified that they
sold alone to another Bank
the new Bank has we listed the house at
80,000 and you're confused the bank does
not get to decide that they at what the
list price of the house is unless they
have foreclosed when you own the home
you put the house on the market the bank
does get to decide if they want to take
a discount on their loan with a short
sale offer but you control the sale
price that you put it on the market for
I think as the house has our account
list it as a foreclosure with no no
listed sale date okay so they have not
foreclosed I I'm not exactly under
pressure how it all works but when I
have called them well the way it works
the way it works is right now the way
the way it works is the house if it has
been foreclosed on an attorney gets the
paperwork runs an ad and they sell your
house at the courthouse steps and you no
longer own it now has that occurred or
not no that has not occurred okay then
the house is still and owned by you and
you should have it on the market with a
realtor and be taking that bank offers
on a short sale and that gets rid of the
house
but in that all avoid a foreclosure for
some reason they've not pursued the
foreclosure because by now you've got to
be at least a year behind aren't you yes
we are
yeah it's it's BA it's good what type of
a loan FHA VA or conventional or the
conventional it is a conventional okay
yeah you want to fight to get this house
sold on a short sale without recourse
which means that you may you know you
put the house on the market for whatever
67,000 you get an offer for 60 again
or 62 or whatever you take that to the
bank and try to force them and you have
to bug the crap out of them because
they're understaffed and they're
incompetent as you have found and you
when you're dealing with Bank of America
you're dealing with a black hole of
idiocy and so you just get sucked into
the vortex of foolishness and that's
what happened thank god they sold the
debt at least maybe now you got a chance
who's got the debt now it's someone I
haven't ever heard of before it's called
like clear water or something like that
it's not a bank name I recognize but I
have even called a mortgage counseling
group and they have called as a third
party with me on the phone and tried to
get them to say that short seller is in
foreclosure and making it's in
foreclosure and they now it doesn't
matter it's not been foreclosed on if
they've not set a foreclosure date they
can still take an offer okay there's not
a you know all that is is just which
file they've got it in at the mortgage
company and you know they they have the
ability legally if you can get through
get through to somebody that has two
brain cells to rub together to accept an
offer for the loan and you know your
loan balances whatever it is 80 grand
now probably and with all the back
payments and interest and everything
and so they have the carding is ninety
eight thousand dollars reading the six
percent and everything they're going to
so and so go ahead my question is so we
make fifty eight thousand a year so we
owe a hundred and thirty five thousand
with the debt that's going to be the
difference between what it sells for and
what they say we owe
my question is when is it time to
declare bankruptcy and can you go into
the ministry after declaring bankruptcy
do you feel that you can I don't think
you're bankrupt I think you have a house
that you need to get rid of and when you
do a short sale you don't owe the
difference if you do it without recourse
meaning that you don't owe the
difference you want them to accept the
offer has settlement on the mortgage a
debt and then the only debt you would
have after that is what thirty five
thousand dollars or whatever your other
debts are and so you know and are you
disqualified from ministry because you
went through a bankruptcy no not in most
cases I mean some denominations might be
that legalistic but most aren't you know
most people that are in ministry that
I've ever met aren't perfect and all of
them have a past of some kind some some
are more gloriously horrible than others
but it's you know that that's there so
no it doesn't disqualify you but you are
you know just regardless of the ministry
aspect of this you are it's good for you
to fight your way through this and get
rid of this house and so you guys need
to take control the situation what I
would do is get on the phone or jump
online at Dave Ramsey comm and find one
of our endorsed local providers in the
area and let them take a hold of this
short sale and run it you need a realtor
that knows how to run a short sale and
they can run the thing down and get it
done and that's what I would do
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you